Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are not going to marvel at neural
network-based AI systems, but we are going
to defeat them. What? How? Well, of course,
not with brute force, but with trickery.
You see, this is what we call an adversarial
attack. And few know about it, but many modern
AI techniques are quite vulnerable against
them. This is the “You Shall Not Pass” game,
where the red agent is trying to hold
back the blue character and not let it
cross the line. Here you see two regular
AIs duking it out, sometimes the red wins,
sometimes the blue is able to get through. Nothing
too crazy here. This is the reference case which
is somewhat well balanced. Now, look closely,
because here comes the hacker adversarial agent.
Ha! Yes, you are seeing correctly, this chap
it doing nothing. Absolutely nothing. But it
is doing nothing in a way that reprograms
its opponent to make mistakes and behave
close to a completely randomly acting
agent! This paper was absolute insanity.
A different adversarial attack paper showed an
interesting case where we were able to take an
image of a horse. The attacked neural network
indeed recognized that this was a horse. However,
when changing just one pixel, an otherwise quite
competent AI now thinks that this is a frog. Note
that this does not mean that we can just change
any pixel anywhere. This is a sophisticated attack
that knows who it is attacking and how this
one pixel difference will reprogram its brain.
Similar attacks also exist that do this
with a little more flavor. Look. This
is a bus. And this is noise. And when we
add this together, do we get a bus+noise?
Nope, what we get is an
ostrich. So does the AI think.
Now, let’s have a look at
new papers with new attacks,
first against AIs that can
play Go. Now, wait a second,
what is really new here? We have heard
players reporting before that with AlphaZero,
they have experienced little hiccups where the
AI made suboptimal moves in an otherwise really
well played game. Why is that news? Why write
a paper about this? How is this one different?
What makes this attack interesting
is that this is not a one-off fluke,
this is an AI that finds systematic flaws in
other neural network-based systems. This means
that they are not only able to exploit
their weaknesses and win against them,
but they can do it on a consistent basis. In
other words, they can win over and over again.
In this case, hold on to your papers, because
this paper describes an attack that is able to
defeat KataGo in 97% of the games. That number is
unreal. Let me explain why. From what I have seen,
KataGo seems to be even stronger than AlphaZero
and AlphaGo Zero, DeepMind’s legendary systems
that are able to beat the best human players
in the world. They authors note that it works
on many AlphaGo-based systems, and it
likely works on AlphaGo variants too.
What makes it even more impressive is that
this adversary was trained from scratch and
did not use any human knowledge.
It found this out all by itself.
And finally, here is another attack against
a competent image recognition AI. When
showing it the Starry Night painting
by van Gogh, which it will, of course,
recognize as shown the by red frame. However, as
we start adding carefully crafted noise to it,
nothing happens. But wait just a little
more, as we continue the process,
bam! Now this noise looks nothing like Starry
Night, but not according to this AI. It would
swear that this is exactly the Starry Night
painting. And this works for other examples too.
The goal of all this is to show you some
of the weaknesses of recent AI systems.
This is a really interesting new field
where we have these powerful new tools,
but this also means that they
have their own limitations too,
and sometimes, it is not at all obvious
what they are. More research is required.
Now, one word about the LK99, the
room-temperature superconductor
project. I see that many of you Fellow
Scholars would love an episode on it,
however, I do not have the required knowledge
to comment on it. Obviously it would be a very
good thing for views, but that doesn’t
matter. What matters is that you Fellow
Scholars get the quality of videos that
you expect here. That is what matters.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!